Dirty John has just dropped on Netflix
and the show expertly depicts just how
much of a master manipulator and conman
that the titular character was those
who've watched the show will know that
at the end of every episode there is a
disclaimer that states that due to the
nature of the series some of the events
have been changed slightly from real
life but just how accurate is the season
as a whole and is it's terrifying finale
what really went down in real life well
throughout this video I'll be breaking
down everything that you need to know
about the real-life John Meehan as well
as some of the things that the show
didn't cover there will be heavy
spoilers in regards to the TV
counterpart so if you haven't seen the
entire run yet then I highly suggest
that you turn off now for everyone else
I'm definition and welcome to the
channel where I watch it so you don't
have to John Meehan was taught the art
of the con from an early age by his
father who ran a casino in San Jose in
his youth he was given lessons on how to
lie and deceive people and John quickly
became an expert at this that easily
manipulated women due to his good looks
and charm Meehan attended Prospect High
School in California and was described
as a magnet for girls due to his
athletic ability and personal side this
was matched by his intelligence and his
sisters stated that it was at this point
in his life that he realized his gifts
provided shortcuts that would allow him
to ultimately control people and achieve
his goals in the show Eric Bana who
plays the character manages to influence
a lot of people early on and convinces
Debra's mother that he's a good man
purely down to his looks in real life
this charm eventually led John to be
under the impression that somehow the
rules didn't apply to him and that he
was above the law he began selling
cocaine and at one point even put broken
glass in fast food to sue a company to
get money from a settlement eventually
Meehan met and married his first wife
Tanya cells in the show we see this play
out pretty similar to real life with
Tanya helping the character through
nursing school to the point that he was
able to gain employment at a hospital
even though she pretty much made his
career
after 10 years John filed for divorce
leaving her and their two children
behind trouble quickly followed when
cells discovered a box of stolen
anaesthetic in her home and after
contacting the police she was harassed
hourly by Meehan and even received
numerous death threats
Meehan didn't stop there though and he
continued stealing from patients that he
was pretending to medicate we see this
in the show too when John fails to
medicate a patient properly for his own
devices eventually due to this he lost
his job and in 2002 he pled guilty to
felony drug theft however instead of
facing up to the charges Meehan went on
the run and tried to obeyed the law
eventually the police caught him barely
conscious and hide from one of the drug
kits that he had stolen from the
hospital but his escape attempts didn't
stop there and the ambulance on the way
to the hospital
Meehan uncuffed himself and tried to run
but he was apprehended and sentenced to
17 months in prison within hours of his
release from jail
Meehan created a match.com profile and
began hunting the vulnerable of rich
females his dating bio read a doctor
with dark hair hazel green eyes and a
charming smile John quickly picked up a
lot of attention due to his picture and
description and this led to his and
Deborah's first date similar to the show
Deborah had just came out of her fourth
divorce and was eager to find someone on
the surface John seemed like a dream
come true and they quickly began
exchanging messages and by the third day
Deborah was besotted by him everything
about him seemed genuine until the
cracks start to show Deborah's
daughter's felt like something was off
about him and stea that he always used
to wear scrubs even to dinner parties
which gave away that perhaps he didn't
have the bank account that he claimed to
Deborah's daughter Jacqueline used to
comment on how he would lustfully stare
over her handbags and expensive clothing
these concerns too were raised by
Deborah's other daughter Tara who
wondered why this high paid doctor
didn't have a car
apartment or anything of value after the
two dug deeper into his past they
quickly unearthed his criminal record as
well as the charges out against him for
harassing women they discovered that in
the past John had posed as a doctor and
extraord women for money and it seemed
like he had his
santipura after being informed of this
deborah quickly split up with John but
as women from his past knew getting rid
of him was easier said than done John
eventually stole her car and set it
alight and threatened to release nude
photos online that she had sent him he
seemed to be on every corner that the
family went and it became clear that he
was stalking them this all came to a
head one night when John attempted to
abduct Tara he pulled out a knife and
slash at her but she fought back bravely
managing to bite down on his hand as
hard as she could as the two tousled
Tara managed to grab hold of the knife
that John had been carrying and she
repeatedly stabbed him over and over
again police arrived at the scene and
found him to be barely breathing in his
car they discovered what was described
as a kidnap kit he's contained duct tape
drugs and a set of kitchen knives it's
clear what his intentions were and no
charges were pressed against her who was
clearly acting in self-defense
John was taken to the hospital but four
days after the attack his life support
was turned off he was given no funeral
and was put into a cremation box but the
horror of his legacy didn't stop there
and his deeds became widespread after
the release of the podcast dirty John
which is what the show is based upon the
podcast is hosted by Christopher
coffered and details the life and events
of John Meehan as well as his
manipulation of Deborah and the final
attack on terror the podcast was
downloaded over 10 million times within
six weeks of its release and it's
definitely worth checking out if you
like true crime stories now on to my
review if you've been following my
channel then you'll know that I
absolutely love true crime stories like
this and dirty Jon didn't disappoint
whilst it didn't live up to the more
fictional tales of shows like you I
still found it fascinating just how
expertly John managed to infiltrate the
characters lives and slowly tear them
apart Eric Bana does an outstanding job
as the titular character and he expertly
handles the charm that John obviously
had Vanna is also able to switch on a
dime and when you start to see his
sinister side unleashed you quickly
understand that this is a man more than
capable of pulling off both facets of
John's personality similar to this
Connie Britton who placed their bro
beautifully handles the vulnerable are
close to sixty woman that would fall for
his charms and the show becomes about
her empowerment which I think is
take I had some gripes with the two
daughters especially Juno Temple who
plays Veronica I found her to be quite
bratty and in that first episode I was
probably on John's side she wasn't
really that likable so I found it
difficult to go along with her overall
though I did have a great time with the
show and definitely recommend that you
check it out if you haven't watched it
yet but if you have then make sure you
leave your thoughts on the show in the
comments below if you have any extra
information I'd love to hear it so leave
that there too and if you enjoyed this
video then please like it and make sure
you check out my breakdown of this
weekend's other big Netflix release the
Umbrella Academy which will be linked at
the end this is a channel for people who
are never missing television so if
that's the kind of thing you like you
need to subscribe to definition thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
you've been the best not see you next
time take care peace
[Music]
[Music]